wolf gunther bernard bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france pour parler de
cette obligation vaccinale qui fait pas
mal débat d'ailleurs en france pourquoi
ce revirement de la part du futur
chancelier olaf scholz ils avaient dit
non à la vaccination obligatoire et
aujourd'hui il va le soumettre cette
idée au parlement
de dire non c'est une
une question de politique bien sûr il
veut pas avoir de
population contre vie gens qui tentent
de nouvelles mauvaises ont pas accepté
et qui donne de bonnes nouvelles est
maintenant bien sûr
évident la réalité elle fait qu' il faut
absolument faire quelque chose
d'efficace
et la seule chose qui a fuit cassis qui
restreint pas complètement la vie
quotidien c'est la vaccination c'est
parfois
des meilleurs peut-être avec
attendre au cabinet ou aux centres de
vaccination et c'est fini et c'est pas
restreindre de sortir un des courses
rencontre des copains etc et les
allemands sont plutôt d'accord ou alors
ça provoque le débat
s'est souvent que les gens qui sont pas
d'accord ils sont le plus fort pour
s'est reposé pour gueuler leur coup mais
je crois à la grande majorité est assez
raisonnable est assez
[Musique]
logique
est de voir que c'est la seule solution
il n'y a pas d'autres pas encore bien
sûr de médicaments ils sont en train de
se créer d'être composé mais jusqu'à
maintenant il n'y a rien du tout qui
peut guérir les qu'ovide alors la
prévention c'est la seule chose qu'on
faire en ce moment c'est étonnant parce
que l'allemagne jusqu'à présent
n'avaient rien imposer à ses concitoyens
on sait que les allemands soient
peut-être un peu plus disciplinés que
les français il fallait vraiment venir à
cette obligation les allemands ne vont
pas se faire vacciner de même
comme je disais c'est pts et surtout
point de vue politique c'était les
élections qui ont fait que les gens les
ont plus peur de dire quelque chose de
deux mauvais de proposer
quelque chose aux gens de force et
faire une pression assez fort mais
maintenant comme les hôpitaux
de département des soins intenses ils
sont archi plein on est obligé de
distribuer déjà des malades en allemagne
parti même à l'étranger et c'est une
triage déjà qui est fille dans certaines
théories et c'est une situation que l'on
peut pas tolérer et comme les gens ils
se sont avérées ou pas assez solidaires
pas assez raisonnable il faut les forcer
il n'y a pas d'autre solution et du coup
donc c'est cette mise en place de
l'obligation vaccinale
aujourd'hui comment est ce qu'elle est
pensée en allemagne comment elle serait
contrôlé il ya des pistes ou pas
c'est pas bien sûr une force
physique les gens ils sont pas cherché
par la police et mis dans les cabinets
c'est
obligatoire et ici les gens ils ne font
pas il faut une porte en skate il faut
payer quelque chose c'est qu'on va tv et
bien sûr avec les temps ci suis pas
encore dans trois mois ou six mois cette
amende elle peut être plus forte et dans
des cas extrêmes on soit on laisse
tomber si c'est moi qui ai un pour cent
ou bien les mythes
punition encore plus fort donc ça veut
dire que ça concernerait les adultes est
ce que les enfants sont concernés et
est-ce qu'il y aurait des contrôles à
l'entrée des entreprises à l'entrée des
magasins comment ça ça devrait se passer
selon vous oui le contrôle il ya déjà
avec le pass sanitaires tout le monde
sent smartphones il a ses marques et les
statues de de vaccination si on est
vacciné une fois deux fois on a eu un
rappel et si on peut pas montrer ça ou
bien des papiers où l'écart n'est pas
d'importance probablement à partir de
février ils vont avoir des problèmes
mais comme je le disais c'est pas une
force physique c'est ils sont unis c'est
comme tel lien qui s'égarent mal on va
pas les sortir de là avec la police mais
va avoir 100 télé et si c'est pas
possible autrement il faut ça ursula von
der leyen qui s'est dit favorable
elle alla à une vaccination obligatoire
sur sur tout le continent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous en
tant que médecin
j'ai pas compris
est-ce qu'il faut que cette obligation
vaccinale elles soient élargies à toute
l'europe comme le souhaite ursula von
der leyen
elle serait le mieux parce que il ya
quand même certaines pays qui sont
d'emblée mois
fort moi
dessinée comme l'angleterre
souhaitent ils ont d'emblée déjà fait
voie de
chose actifs et là ce serait bien
possible que l'un des grands avantages
si eux aussi les horaires de vaccination
obligatoire c'est-à-dire celle de brett
partout au monde parce que on voit le
variant ils viennent justement de
régions de pays où il n'y a pas de
vaccin afrique du sud brésil inde où il
ya une grande partie de la population et
pas vacciner que pensez vous du fait de
vacciner certaines catégories de
population ceux qui sont fragiles et
ceux qui risque d'en mourir est ce qu'on
ne devrait pas limiter la vaccination
finalement à ces personnes là qui
engorgent aujourd'hui les hôpitaux en
allemagne
ça c'est plus nécessaire parce qu'il
s'était déjà fait il ya très peu de gens
de très vieux ou chroniquement malades
qui sont refusés parce que bon quand on
est malade ans on voit la réalité
peut-être mieux que quand on est jeune
on a 30 ans 40 ans et on croit ya rien
qui peut attaquer on n'est pas tous
fiables par quoi que ce soit alors aux
lois 90% des gens comme ça ils sont déjà
vaccinés mais comme les vaccins ils ont
pas
les filles on espère y croyez après une
vaccination il ya 95% de protection et
ça va durer un peu plus leur maintenant
on voit qu elle même avec les rappels on
peut avoir des riches et on peut avoir
le problème est maintenant c'est les
jeunes qui traînent dans les hôpitaux et
dans le
soit à la danse et surtout qu'ils sont
pas vaccinés qui sont entre 30 et 60 ans
c'est pas le vieux et ses chroniques mmm
à la merci beaucoup wolf gunther
beernaert pour autre éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france sur la situation en
allemagne je le rappelle vous êtes
médecin généraliste à munich